welcome to wired's gadget challenge the
show where eric and justin from battle
damage test out the coolest products
ripped from the pages of wired magazine
this week gifts to check out your
workout
today we're testing out three awesome
fitness gifts we've got the withings
pulse o2 watch the sunset led skateboard
and first up these jaybird bluetooth
earbuds the blue buds x by j bird boast
improved sound quality through their
custom shift premium bluetooth audio
technology with a battery life of eight
hours the blue buds will fit any workout
routine you can throw at them
to test out the blue buds we decided to
have a little duel to see who could
untangle a pair of regular earbuds first
all while wirelessly listening to our
favorite power jams
three paces
oh man this is hard with a gun i think
i'm making it worse
oh no
triumphant blue team
why the withings pulse o2 watch is the
perfect workout companion it tracks
steps elevation distance and calories
burned plus monitors your heart rate
sleep cycles and even blood oxygen level
all right to test the pulse o2 watches
we've each got this 300 calorie slice of
pizza we're gonna scarf down and see who
can burn off the most calories in two
minutes such a bad idea someone's gonna
throw up okay
and eight
i'm already full lunch is right after
this i'm getting the meat sweats i don't
feel like i'm gonna barf yet two minutes
on the clock
now
i think i've burned like 80 calories
0.19 miles eight calories that was it
eight calories we will use the amount of
steps
as a tie breaker 266
302
we have a winner all right let me get
another slice of pizza yeah give me one
too the sunset led skateboard features
four high-intensity led lights and a
self-powered design meaning this baby
requires no batteries
for our final competition we're testing
these awesome led skateboards by seeing
who can do the fastest lap on our
nighttime track justin burst and go
oh good turn around
18.4 seconds beat that
and try to look cooler eric next this is
for all the marbles man this is for the
episode go
what does that count as the board's
still there
you got to take that board
19.53
you were going to kill me i fell i flew
too close to the sun
remember you can check out more
information on any of the things we
tested in today's episode by clicking
the links down there in the description
make sure and watch the rest of the
videos in this series especially our
tour of the new york city wired store
for more gifts and gadgets to make your
life better check out the wired store
opening in new york city in december and
make sure to subscribe to the wired
channel